after 11 games in the main series you
might think that there's no life left in
Tomb Raider but that's not true 2013's
reboot sparked life back into the series
and are the scrappiest cleverest and
let's face it clumsiest lady in gaming
is back for another round lady Lara
treks to Siberia and Syria to uncover
the mysteries of the lost city of gitesh
and chases down the secret to
immortality rise of the Tomb Raider is a
game made by its own history but isn't
afraid to switch up its famous formula
so in this episode of in two minutes
brought to you by our friends at Xbox
here's what to look out for while
multiplayer may be lost to the archives
there's still a way to pit yourself
against others expedition mode chained
together kills to earn high scores and
rise up through the leaderboards you can
even mod levels to your liking with
expedition cards they gain modifiers
that you can either buy with money
earned in game or purchased using
real-world fun bucks after the sense of
mild satisfaction that comes with
opening a card back you can choose how
to tweak your game from activating big
head mode or removing health
regeneration to giving yourself a sweet
new weapon you can truly play Tomb
Raider your way some people use apps
audio tapes for some two years of
language classes to learn rudimentary
Spanish but for Lara it's as easy as
reading some words in the language she's
trying to learn and then magically
picking up the tongue without a
translation whatever its video games but
improving Lara's language proficiency is
key to grabbing collectibles as
translating monoliths reveals the
location of coins and relics on her map
and also has the bonus of looking really
good to would-be employers it feels a
bit strange to say that tombs are back
in Tomb Raider but there are plenty in
rise of the Tomb Raider way more so than
in 2013's reboot now while they're
completely optional miss out at your
peril not only do you get the chance to
take in some truly breathtaking scenery
you also get that feeling of triumph
after besting a particularly tricky
physics-based puzzle and instead of
modern weapon pieces lining in millennia
old tomb you learn ancient knowledge and
skills
passed down to help you destroy evil
people combat remains as scrappy as ever
but Lara's a fast learner and has
figured out even more ways of
dispatching nefarious Trinity troops
from lining up multiple shots with her
bow to death from above Lara's guerrilla
combat style can be tuned to your liking
like rigging up a corpse to be a ticking
time bomb or taking advantage of the
multitude of crafting resources in the
world to create poison arrows from some
mushrooms The Beatles said it best you
get by with a little help from your
friends and in Tomb Raider that's
certainly the case by helping out allies
that you come across you can earn some
tasty weapon upgrades as well as warm
fuzzy feelings your kind acts of charity
so there's just some things to look out
for in rise of the Tomb Raider sadly the
game does not feature a butler nor
fridge to lock him in if you fancy
digging into more of Lara's adventures
be sure to cast your gaze over to
gamespot com for all of your rise of the
Tomb Raider needs thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time for some more
in two minutes
you